okay NBC News has this report Senate
Majority Leader Chuck Schumer has
quietly changed the Senate's informal
dress code to allow Senators to wear
whatever they want on the floor a person
with direct knowledge said a notice went
out to the Senate sergeant of arms and
relevant staff members late Friday and
the change will go into effect starting
Monday the change will that Senator John
fedman who was often seen wearing a
hoodie and baseball shorts wear his
casual attire on the senate floor
whenever he wants fedman who was elected
in late uh in last year's midterm
elections wore a suit and tie at his
swearing in in January but um I guess
has not uh worn it since however he's
worn his casual clothes after returned
to the Senate following treatment for
clinical depression this year um so
there's been a lot of conversation about
this including over on The View and as
always we know there's great Insight
being provided by those women who uh I
think are you know in many ways the
philosophers of our age principal among
them would be whoopy Goldberg and here's
what she had to say about it so
yesterday Chuck Schumer ended the dress
code uh in Washington because they all
have to wear suits and skirts and
dresses and stuff uh and uh really did
kind of a really wonderful thing for uh
John
fedman uh and people are upset on the
other side of the aisle they think this
is not something that should have been
done that it shouldn't have been changed
now what's interesting is this this kind
of for me highlights an issue that the
other side off often has because which
is which
is it's okay if you don't want to wear
shorts and a sweat Sho uh sweatsuit
you're not obligated to but this is a
guy who votes with one leg in and one
leg out because he doesn't want to
interrupt the flow of good-looking
people in their suits and dresses
and Schumer said you know what let me be
thoughtful let's lighten it up so you
can be more comfortable here mhm I think
that's great because it's not saying
that everybody has to do it it's saying
you can do it you can if you don't if
you've been feeling my God I'd just
rather wear pants so more great insight
there from the The View and I mean look
on on the one hand with this dress code
thing you could make the argument that
these DC politicians are a bunch of
scumbags and anyway so why even
bother with the formality uh you might
as well abolish the dress code because
because they're just a bunch they're
just most of them are absolute scum like
the drgs of humanity in D not all of
them but most of them and U maybe
there's like three that don't that
aren't sorry so um you could say well so
yeah just have them all look like
slovenly bums as John fedman does all
the time why not and you can make that
argument but that's not the argument
that I will make because I happen to
believe in dress codes and even though I
wear flannel every day on this show but
there you know there are environments
where you're supposed to put in more
effort um and you're supposed to meet a
certain standard of dress and if you're
elected to the Senate then you should be
held to that
standard you know the idea that the most
important thing in the world is for
people to be comfortable is just
absolutely wrongheaded and stupid and uh
I always like to flip this around
because people like to say oh well what
do you need a dress code what do you
need a dress code for well how about
this why can't you abide by it what's so
difficult
what no we don't have to you've got
something like a dress code that's been
in place uh forever everybody abides by
it and then you come along and say what
do we need this for no we're not the
ones who have to explain ourselves to
you people always get this wrong when it
comes to dress codes or anything else
when there's a when there's a tradition
a custom a way that things are done and
everybody's doing it that way and then
you come along is say why should I have
to do it it it it no you're putting the
burden of proof on us like we have to
explain ourselves to you no no no no you
you need to explain yourself why
shouldn't you do
it okay why shouldn't you why can't
you why can't John fedman put a damn
suit on is he a child is he a big oish
overgrown child or is he a grown man an
elected
official you know we know he's making
six figures he can afford a suit he can
at least afford to run down to Men's
Warehouse and buy a a few suits they've
always got a special like buy 10 suits
for you know 95 and get the 11th one
free so you could go out you could buy
some suits he just doesn't feel like it
he doesn't want to he wants to walk
around every day looking like uh looking
like I look when I make an 11:30 pm. run
to Walmart and yeah if you're at Walmart
11:30 p.m. or really any time of day uh
you can look as disheveled as you want
because that per tradition in that
institution that's the tradition at
Walmart uh if anything it it goes the
other way if you look too formal at
Walmart then it's it's you know you're
out of dress code
so but if you can't be bothered to abide
by a simple dress code in the
Senate then you don't deserve to be
there and if you can't treat you know
it's funny that we we hear so much about
the sacred Halls after January 6 the
sacred Halls at Capitol Hill and
Congress and it's it's sacred it's a
sacred Place
sacred it's so sacred you can't even
bother to put a suit on
and it I it just it blows my mind with
John fedman in
particular the way that we talk about
him and treat this guy we treat him
literally like he's a child the guy's
the United States Center and whoopy
Goldberg is sitting there saying oh good
for him he can wear his shorts that'll
make him comfortable he's a good boy
you're a good boy Johnny just wear what
you want as long as long as you're
comfortable are you having fun you want
to a juice box are you a little hungry
did you bring your lunch to you need a
Lunchable did your mommy pack you did
your mommy pack you a lunch
Johnny we treat this guy like he's a you
know special needs it it's it's ridic a
United States
Senator and this by the way is is is I
believe that this was part of the reason
why the stay at the hospital I think
this was part of call me
cynical I am but the moment John fedman
got elected and everybody was talking
about is this guy even capable of you
know of Performing the functions of the
office and then and then he gets elected
and the moment he gets elected pretty
much he's checking into a hospital with
mental issues and depression and and the
thing is the moment that happened it was
like this hush this silence fell over
him and suddenly you're not allowed to
criticize him anymore you're not allowed
to hold him to any kind of
standard and he's in the hospital for
for days on end
and he's a United States senator who
just got elected and he's in the
hospital with depression and no one's
allowed to ask any questions about it
like what the hell what's going on you
can't you should step down if you can't
do the job if you're not emotionally
capable what What's Happening Here how
is this okay you know what company's
looking out for you when they actually
upgrade your service and don't charge
you for it this is great news for new
and current Pure Talk customers P talk
just added data to every plan and
includes a mobile Hotspot with no price
increase whatsoever if you've considered
peer talk before but haven't made the
switch take a look again for just $20 a
month you'll get unlimited talk text and
now 50% more 5G data plus their new
mobile hotspot this is why I love Pure
Talk they're veteran-owned and only hire
the best customer service team located
right here in the great USA most
families are saving almost $1,000 a year
while enjoying the most Dependable 5G
Network in America remember you vote
with how you spend your money so stop
supporting woke wireless companies that
don't support you when you go to P
talk.com Walsh you'll save an additional
50% off off your first month because
they actually value you that's Pur
talk.com Walsh Pure Talk Wireless for
Americans by Americans no if you're if
you're elected as a senator you you
cannot be checking yourself in to
hospitals for mental health problems you
need to step down from your position if
you're doing that and that is so obvious
and no one would say it like we all know
that but the moment that happens the
moment you know once you claim
depression or something it's like oh
it's week we can't say anything that's
insensitive uh and so I think that this
was it was it was at least partially
calculated because now we treat this guy
like he's a damn
toddler and it was at least partially
there was a calculation I believe put
him in the hospital get the sympathy
points up and then uh and then next
thing you know we changing the dress
code for this guy and he's walking
around babbling nonsense he's babbling
nonsense he cannot string he literally
cannot listening to him talk you feel
like you're having a stroke uh because
it doesn't what he's saying doesn't make
any
sense and that we're not supposed to
notice either you can't can't notice
can't comment it's
insensitive you say too many mean things
he might end up back in the hospital
with a mental health issue and that'll
be your
fault it is such an embarrassment I mean
uh and I know in some ways it seems like
this seems like a moot point also
because um because the I mean all these
people are embarrassing us all the time
but this thing with fetman in particular
it
is it's the kind of thing that
historians are going to look back
on uh and they're going to not that
that's going to be one of those moment
when they're tracing the decline and
collapse of uh you know United States
American society that's going to be one
of the sort of landmark moments is when
this guy was elected and allowed to stay
an office even though he he's has lost
his mind completely thanks for checking
out this video if you'd like to listen
to my full podcast on the go you can
check out the Matt wall show on Apple
podcast Spotify or wherever you get your
podcasts